the principles of design are how we use
the elements of design
they are rules that help to create an
effective composition that clearly
delivers a message to the audience
the eight principles of design are
emphasis
contrast
balance
repetition
pattern
movement
rhythm
and unity and variety
the use of these basic principles can
help a design piece stand out
without them there's a good chance that
the design will be ineffective
the first principle of design is
emphasis
emphasis is when an area of the
composition is visually dominant and
catches the viewer's attention placement
of a dominant element is critical to
design without emphasis the arrangement
of elements will not be as interesting
as it could be and the eye will be
confused
emphasis can often be achieved through
contrast
contrast is the juxtaposition of
opposing elements of design and a
composition
this could be elements like
complementary colors
different directions
tonal differences
and textural differences
contrast creates space and difference
between elements and design contrasting
elements demand the viewer's attention
and allow us to highlight key elements
contrast can make a design pop
balance is the distribution of the
visual weight of the composition weight
can come from color
shapes
size or texture
the arrangement of elements does not
allow a singular element to overpower
another
balance provides stability and structure
to a design and makes it feel stable
symmetrical balance means that elements
mirror one another on either side of a
center line
asymmetrical balance means the
composition sides are different but
still look balanced and have equilibrium
radial balance means that the elements
are arranged around a central point
and may be similar
repetition of elements creates unity
within the composition
by tying together individual elements a
composition is strengthened
repetition helps to create consistency
it can also create pattern
repetition without variation becomes
pattern
repetition works with pattern to make
the design seem active
and pattern is the uniform repetition of
any of the elements of design
[Music]
movement is the path the viewer's eye
takes through the composition
the eye is led to move from one focal
point to the next
movement can be created by lines
space
repetition shapes
color
and more
rhythm is a feeling of organized
movement
it is created when one or more elements
of design are repeated
rhythm creates mood and gives the
impression of activity
unlike pattern which demands consistency
rhythm relies on variety
variety is the use of multiple elements
of design to keep the viewers attention
and unity is the feeling of harmony
between all of the elements
too much unity creates monotony
and too much variety creates chaos
but both are needed to create areas of
interest in a composition
and that's the eight principles of
design
the more you study design the more
varied the list becomes
some add to the list and some subtract
from it
but a design doesn't have to strictly
follow these principles to be considered
good
rules are made to be broken and there
are many amazing designs out there that
ignore one or more of the principles
the principles of design are
interchangeable blocks which combine to
tell a story
understand and practice these principles
after that you can break the rules and
create your own style